what were you like as a kid were you an
unusual kid in any way were you sure yes
pretty unusual youngest of four so I was
a little bit of a troublemaker I kind of
I just like you know I was looking I'm
always looking for the status quo and
then I run the opposite direction so
you'd like to try and just make a splash
make a make a commotion make your mark
no that was like yeah the immature
version of it what's like the worst
thing you did well I the one that I get
heat for is still to this day for my
mother is I brought a big bread knife to
school and kindergarten like I snuck it
nice yeah it was had like the curved and
yeah I put it in my in my like sock yeah
and I went to school telling all the
kids like my grandfather got this in
World War two we used to slice Germans
he was a baker in the war yeah so I mean
but you know there was plenty of lying
fabricating really just training to be
in Hollywood
yes exactly
I got a knife here right now
I want to get the word out like I need
to get the word out it's very popular
high-maintenance
airs on Sundays at 10:30 on HBO thank
you it's also streaming on HBO go and
HBO now and it's a really special show
and you should check it out
Benson Claire great job Thanks
[Applause]